last time on the ozempic Diaries hey there
just thought I'd do a quick awesome pick
check-in it is day 44 in my journey I have
done hang on a second seven doses so four at
.25 milligrams and three at point five
I'm down about four pounds so you know
that's not too bad my last dose of the 0.5
next week I'll be up at the one milligrams
I do feel like ozempic right now is acting as
my like support system and it's not allowing
me to overeat that's one thing that I
will say like I'm not overeating at all
hey everyone welcome back
to Abby's kitchen [Music]
today we'll be catching back up with my friend
and business partner ginger on month three of our
Olympic journey and today we'll be discussing
rapid weight loss cooking without an appetite
transparency and a zenpic for food noise a quick
disclaimer here that this video includes numbers
calories Extreme Weight Loss discussion also
please note that the individual in the series
is not my client so any suggestions are for
general knowledge and education purposes only
also a reminder that the purpose of this
series isn't to promote ozempic or weight
loss in general is to counter a lot of the
myths and disinformation about ozempic with
honesty transparency and evidence-based practice
Evelyn's needs are going to be unique and should
always be discussed one-on-one with your health
care provider so to quickly just catch us all up
Ginger did a month of 0.25 milligrams then
a month at 0.5 and in this video she'll be
doing the one milligram dose for a month and
starting the 1.5 milligram dose so in other
words we are finally reaching the clinical
dosage now before we get talking to Ginger
let's take a look at some of her video diaries
this is my second dose at one milligram I will
say that I've lost another couple pounds
this week this past week I felt like it was
like it was you know I've been looking at
food I'm like man it doesn't really like
impress me much the one thing I will say
that when I took the one milligram doses
that I'm exhausted I've never been so tired
of my life so ozethic exhaustion is quirky
it actually apparently doesn't affect everyone
and is still considered a more rare side effect
and it's probably because a lot of people who
are on ozempic also have high blood sugars so
if you take it for weight loss instead while
having healthy normal blood sugar levels then
it's possible that it can lower your blood
sugar lower than what you're used to and can
cause temporary lethargy as your body just
kind of gets used to it I actually had the
same experience when I was put on Metformin for
IVF because my blood sugars were normal before I
took the drug so I ended up getting these really
uncomfortable lows as a not so great side effect
so again as uncomfortable as it is this should
level out over time it is my third dose of
confused and a little bit sad because I didn't
see any progress this week and I worked out every
single day except yesterday including three of
those days being double headers I'm getting a
little concerned I gained a pound this week I'm
still eating I'm just not thinking about food all
the time which I guess is good it's just it's so
hard not to see the progress that I want to see so
I don't know so that's why weekly weigh-ins aren't
always representative of progress especially
without any kind of professional one-on-one
guidance if I were gingers Rd and I was doing
these measurements and weigh-ins I would also be
looking at these blips in the context of what else
might be going on that day or week so for example
where are you in your cycle did you eat a very
salty meal the night before if you were to weigh
yourself in a few days would it be different I
really encourage people not to get too hung up on
the individual numbers on individual days the fact
that she's not thinking about food all the time
feels like huge progress to me even if it resulted
in very little weight loss this week just imagine
how much space that opens up in your mind and life
for things that bring you Joy and over time as
you're thinking and obsessing less over food
the weight very likely will come down I also you
know after the last conversation with Abby I don't
think I ate very well so I went to farm boy which
is my favorite go-to and picked up like pre-made
salads for this week some salmon um some veg we'll
see how that goes I'm just like not in the mood to
cook listen I'm rarely in the mood to cook now
that I've got kids who are just gonna Chuck it
on the ground so no judgment for me on that but
I do think that obviously losing interest in food
and reducing the drive to eat is absolutely going
to have the side effect of reducing the drive to
do the labor of making the food like the food is
kind of the fun part but we still need to nourish
ourselves even when we don't really feel like
it so some other really easy convenient options
include rotisserie chicken canned tuna Frozen
cooked shrimp Frozen egg bites smoothie freezer
packets frozen turkey burgers pre-cooked whole
grain pouches or just Add Water oats there's also
now a ton of grocery store meal kits where you
can just kind of like dump everything into the
pan so at least you don't have to do the mentally
labor of deciding what to make one ounce of cheese
donate me Ginger she knew I was gonna have to say
something about this and I will to her but I get
the old diet habits die hard and Ginger's Paulie
spent a lot of her life putting these on a scale
but the goal for us on ozempic is to no longer
need to track or meticulously weight portions
so we need to start to get used to feeling and
honoring those new Hunger and fullness cues and
that means kind of going in blind so I would
personally just kind of cut a few slices of
cheese and simply eat until satiated see what that
feeling feels like and obviously we want to tackle
one thing at a time and that Letting Go piece is
key but once we've got that down then of course
we can think about turning it into hunger crush
and combo by adding an egg or two and some toast
and fruit so I really think that the experience of
just letting go of some of those old diet crutches
is the really important piece here you gotta
trust ozempic to do its job because as ginger
has started self it's like her little helper her
little best friend in her back pocket give your
body the chance to relearn some of these skills
because that is what makes ozepik different from
any other diet you've ever been on I'm still
at one milligram it will be my last dose at
one milligram next week I will be going up to 1.5
I saw a pretty significant weight loss this week
even though I feel like I ate which was is pretty
good so I was down 2.4 pounds in the last week in
terms of symptoms still really tired still of the
diarrhea not relieving nausea although there was
one day this past week where I just really I
don't know if it was just that I wasn't hungry
or was nauseous but I started drinking bone broth
when that was happening and I actually think it's
really helping the whole process so upping my
water intake so this will be the first thing I
have this morning really taking coffee out of
my diet which is crazy I'm upping my water and
I'm adding in bone broth okay I love this for us
cutting down the coffee as we discussed more water
and some bone broth this 100 makes sense to me
there's nothing magical about bone broth but it's
probably helping with symptom management because
a broth is mainly water so again it's adding lots
of hydration and fluids are also better tolerated
than solids because they don't require a lot of
digestion when you're feeling nauseous and B bone
broth contains electrolytes which may be depleted
from diarrhea and also protein which has been
shown to help improve nausea symptoms better than
any kind of like really high fat or higher Sugar
Foods so this is great when you're not feeling
your best and you need a little nourishment bone
broth is a great way to kind of like stimulate
the appetite and get a little bit of fluids and
nourishment in Canadians in case you didn't know
this as you get up past the one milligram dose
which is the therapeutic dose for diabetes and
you go to 1.5 or 2 milligrams we do not yet have
the eight milligram pen in can Canada so I went to
upgrade or up my dose to the 1.5 this week and
I had to pay for two pens so that took me over
500 for this month I've only budgeted 270 dollars
which is the cost to me out of pocket in order to
sustain this I guess I'm gonna have to now wrap
my head until that eight milligram pen comes in
about that extra fee that is a lot like Americans
let me know is it better or worse for you because
at least I think it's somewhat covered by our
health care but yeah even 270 dollars a month
is a lot of a commitment especially when we're
thinking this is a lifelong commitment now the
one milligram I'm really starting to see a little
bit more of a drastic change case in point as of
last week I'm down 12 pounds and I've lost a
total of 12 inches just over 12 inches I know
Ginger was pretty worried that it wasn't working
for her or maybe it wasn't working fast enough
there's always so much going on in our head when
we start these kind of medications so you know
there's definitely some folks who will only need
to take 0.5 milligrams long term but most folks
will probably need between one to two milligrams
to have the desired effect now I know ginger has
a lot to update us on so let's get chatting all
right Ginger so nice to see you again hi hi okay
so first things first you tell everyone as like a
quick little recap why you're doing this and why
we're even doing this together just very quickly
on both sides of my family we suffer from obesity
diabetes heart issues after I went through quite
a lot of hormone treatment for egg freezing and I
had some surgery I had my gallbladder removed and
I had covered for about a year like I was stagnant
like I couldn't move and I just put on too much
weight that was healthy for me like to the point
where I didn't want to move and that's not like me
so I talk to my doctor we consulted with internal
medicine we talked we consulted with the weight
loss clinic in Ottawa and basically the answer
was if I go on ozempic now not only will it help
me you know drop some of this weight uh probably
a little bit quicker than I would be able to on my
own but it would be a preventative measure not to
get diabetes and hurt issues so that's kind of the
research that's coming out now is that it is quite
a life-altering drug especially for those who
suffer or who have family histories of diabetes
and heart issues you know we've washed your your
Clips but tell me like first of all how are you
feeling like symptom-wise how are you feeling
today because things are always changing well
great uh considering I went to a wedding
last night I'm alive and well and you know
I didn't over drink actually that's one of
the symptoms or the side effects of of this
drug is you kind of lose the desire for a lot
of things you were previously like you were
jonesing for so things like alcohol things
like sweets like it's just oh my my desire
for those have been drastically cut back so
um so I feel great so I never have these wild
hangovers anymore which is amazing and like
I can maybe have like two glasses of wine
that is amazing what a feeling to uh it's
pretty amazing yeah and so tell me a little
about progress wise where were you at since
you've lost weight and done some numbers
here today is actually the four month Mark so
I've been on this journey for four months now
um so I will be starting
two milligrams today I know
nervous because this is the dose where everybody
says this is where they experience symptoms so
I'm I'm looking forward to our next chat to see
if I actually have the symptoms that everybody's
experiencing at this dose but I've gone really
gradually so I'm hoping for the best but it's
been four months I've lost 19 pounds wow this one
and a half dose has been the Catalyst of that real
like no I don't want this I'm gonna have a cup of
bone broth and you know some lactose free cottage
cheese and an egg instead like that's been it's
mind-blowing to me how it's changed really what
I'm craving wow yeah so I'm very pleased I'm very
very pleased with the results it's been slow and
because it's been slow you know I've yo-yo diet
my whole diet in my whole life preached anybody
watching we you know we're in this together and
I will say like when you lose weight fast so I
mean I've tried Atkins I've tried it all like
low carb you know all all these things when
you lose weight fast you tend to be skinny fat
you know and whereas because I've been losing it
quite a bit slower and just on like a really nice
Pace I have it also I think I've mentioned this I
work out a lot like I'm doing so much Pilates I'm
probably at Pilates like four to six times a week
and I'm like playing tennis I do know that I have
to get my cardio up in order to but the problem
is when I get my cardio up I get hungry again so
I'm not really I haven't really invested a lot in
the cardio piece so I don't know how his epic
will affect that hunger so stay tuned because
I had kind of earmarked September as being the
month just giving myself I needed to get some
weight off so that it didn't impact my knees
right you've told you took that yeah yeah so
now that I've gotten this 19 pounds off I'm ready
to like get back on the bike get back out and run
things like that so I will let you know how if
that impacts my Hunger overall and that you know
I was gonna ask you about non-weight victories
but just the idea of you being able to get back
on the bike and run which are things that I know
bring you Joy that's a huge non-weight victory
I love it I love it like here I am out of town
and I'm like researching I'm like okay well it's
Toronto so there's every weight or every not
wait sorry every gym class and possible so I'm
like okay what can I do tonight at 6 30. there's
so many I'm so pumped that is a huge on scale
victory for me wow inches too like listen I'm
fitting into like smaller pants that I've just
been have like they've been in my my you know
dresser or my closet just waiting to come out
again I couldn't believe it like when I put them
on I'm like oh my God here we are again excellent
I was so scared to put them on well I mean it
must feel feel really good to to be hitting
these Milestones um and I know you mentioned you
know you're feeling really good today tell me
about some of the things that have helped manage
your symptoms I know we've talked you've talked
about water and bone broth amazing um now that
your symptoms are kind of subsiding what is your
diet looking like right like right now other
than the lone piece of cheese Ginger because
you know I was gonna tell y'all talk to you about
that girl this is the problem so I get into these
these periods where I'm like so focused on the
food and the diet aspect of things and that's
where I'm kind of like stop it because that's what
I don't want and that's why we talked about this
drug and that's why we wanted to go on it because
I wanted my body my brain to make those decisions
without me having to take the scale out and weigh
it yes I was doing that a lot it was almost like
I was inspired because like I was losing the
weight and I'm like okay well now I don't want
to like overeat my calories and here's the thing
so the in the comment section which is one of the
reasons why I wanted to we we wanted to recap
you know what we were going through and why we
were doing this and I want everybody to know and
and you want everybody to know the situation and
we want to let's just a little playback but a
lot of people were like you're eating too many
calories if you're not losing weight and it
was like oh maybe that is it you know and and
that's why I just it was reading those comments
in the sense that got me kind of to take out the
skin scale again and to focus on it but I put
it away as soon as I videotaped that one I'm
like oh my God I'm here I am doing this I gotta
videotape this show her because I've been doing
it a couple of times and I don't want to do it
this is a good reminder for folks who you know
just pretend like you've got me watching and I'm
gonna tell you to hunger crushing combo it friends
um but also a really good reminder that you
know just so everybody knows the clips you
see are such a small snippet of your real life
every single day and that goes for what you see
influencers post as well if you feel possessed
to leave comments in the comments section of
other people's you know recipes or what in days to
say oh yeah no wonder you're fat you ate a donut
have a think that you don't know what they ate
earlier on the day you don't know what they ate
the next day you don't know what they ate over
the course of the week so you really can't say
you're not tracking their calories you're not
there My Fitness Pal app so just keep in the
mind that that it doesn't tell this whole story
what we see online so ginger be kind to yourself
um and and yeah just know that the purpose for
this drug is to be able to reprogram your brain
so that you don't have to make those kinds
of calculated decisions or or lean on these
external indicators of your fullness so in
one of the clips that I watched of yours you
mentioned that people are starting to notice
your your weight loss and you said you know
one of your tennis Partners said that she can
tell that you've been working out which you
obviously have she's can see you doing it do
you ever tell people that you're on a subject
are you open you know when they comment
on your weight loss what do you say yes
very open because I realized that I am getting
some assistance so and because I don't want to
go into the Trap of dieting and the trap of
you look good so that equates to your value
and working hard like I'm really trying not to
go there I don't say oh thanks it's ozempic but
I say thank you so much and if we go into a bigger
conversation about what I'm doing then I will tell
them because I really think like it's not just
ozempic I'm sorry it's not yes it's helping with
the brain and the gut connection and it's really
helping curb those Cravings that I so used to like
want like the pasta this the sweets oh my God the
sweets like it's just gone and it's that's the
radical difference for me so I am being open and
honest about it I think it's important because I
think if anybody wants to make a change in their
life I think knowing that there are tools but not
crutches is really important yeah I I think that's
absolutely true and you know I I always say I
don't think anyone owes anyone an explanation or
information when it comes to their body or their
health you know and you Ginger you're not an
influencer that's out there coming on Instagram
saying like oh look at me I lost 50 pounds by
doing this program and you can buy it for me from
199 et cetera Etc like that to me is unethical
that's kind of like the Ali Larter liposuction
gate and Legally Blonde situation where you know
they're trying to sell you on on their body as
their business card when perhaps they had plastic
surgery or in this case are using ozempic but I
yeah I I applaud you for for coming out here and
being open with everyone on this journey to try
to help to destigmatize these things which at the
end of the days is I think really important that
we need to destigmatize medication and we need
to destigmatize people in larger body taking
efforts to improve their health if that's what
they choose to do um and making choices about
their own body and what feels good to them young
exactly and and you know there's the opposite
argument Abby I think we've spoken about this
as well is there's the opposite argument that
you know if we're trying to destigmatize what
this drug could do what about people saying oh
you're overweight just take ozampic like we don't
want to create that either so I'm actually making
a conscious effort that when I see somebody who
looks fantastic I'm not commenting on their body
anymore because I don't want to imply anything so
I'm saying you look so happy like I love you so
I love that that's actually a general rule of
mine I just generally do not comment on people's
bodies whether they look different whether they
look the same whatever it may be comment I like
your dress I like your purse I like you know you
look super happy you know you're you're glowing
you know whatever it may be there's something
there that they can take from it whatever they
want but you're not specifically adding fuel to
that fire because we never know why someone's body
looks the way that it does we don't know if what
if they've lost weight because of illness we don't
know if they've lost weight because of sadness or
a disordered eating Etc we never want to reinforce
that we know that criticism doesn't help motivate
people that making them feel shamed about their
body doesn't make them want to exercise or
eat healthier it typically does the opposite
it drives them further into whatever behaviors
landed them there in the first place so that's
just a general rule of thumb to everyone keep your
opinions of people's bodies to themselves I think
when you really think about it it's like why are
you paying such close attention to my body anyway
like that's us so anyways that's how I always
think about it I'm like it's kind of gross so
I think that's good for everyone now two sides to
the coin you know two sides story we'll see what
happens in a year from now I wish celebrities
who are 140 pounds weren't taking it to get
to the vanity 115 120. uh you know unless they're
dealing with PCOS right or history of diabetes or
a history of heart disease unless they're trying
to treat something proactively right which we'll
never know so it's really not up to us to make
criticisms or judgments in general you're right I
just think the media has kind of run rampant with
this storyline and it's doing a disservice to all
of us totally yeah but it's been really good for
Nova norvo or Nova it's a company that creates has
been huge the media typically doesn't do us much
good let's be honest so I want to actually get
to some of the comments and questions that I saw
come up in the last video and there was actually
a lot of comments about this idea of food noise
so there was one person who said the absence of
food noise that I've experienced on Jose because
being worth its weight in gold I didn't realize
how much I'm exhausted myself mentally thinking
about food I was like is this what it's like to
be a normal person it's so helpful and this me I
don't know Ginger I know you've experienced this
this seems like such a huge non-weight Victory
give me your your thoughts huge right actually
I'm going to put this in another way for people
who may not have the food noise anxiety Until you
realize that that sense of worry is actually
a disconnect you know anxiety is the perfect
way to describe what the food noise is so very
similar thing I remember asking friends like like
if you said the wrong thing to someone do you not
worry about that for five days days and they were
like no that's when I knew something was wrong
same same when I talked to my husband at some
of my my thoughts and I realize how different
I am I'm like oh not everyone stays up late at
night ruminating over a simple conversation
with a stranger okay I have both yeah yeah
but no the food noise when that being gone it's
so true what this person said because that mental
exhaustion is real you get it with anxiety you
get it with food noise I mean I used to wake up
thinking about food where like it's almost like
this I don't know if it was that mentality of
scarcity like where's my next meal gonna come
from am I gonna eat lunch like what am I gonna
do how am I gonna plan my day okay what's the
work back schedule you know how am I gonna get
come on yeah it's a lot are you hungry banana yeah
you know get an egg you know totally but I never
never had that and you know there was another
really interesting uh question about food noise
so Aaron asks should those epic be available
for everyone who has food noise and who can't
eat intuitively and who maybe are not living in a
larger body I don't know what your thoughts are on
this Ginger but I will say that obviously this is
ultimately a question for doctors and researchers
in this field from my perspective as a dietitian
and also someone who has an anxiety like you and
have experienced a lot of Psych drugs and things
like that I think with all medications there are
risks and benefits here so weight loss may be a
benefit to someone but it may be a risk to another
person I know Society always thinks if weight loss
as this like good thing but it wouldn't be a good
thing for me for example like I wouldn't see that
as a benefit so typically folks with food noise
from like reward system disruptions do tend to
gain weight whereas some folks have food noise
because of caloric restriction so the former
may be a candidate while the latter it would
be contraindicated so again I think that it's
possible but I I think that would be something
that you'd have to discuss one-on-one with your
doctor to weigh those risks and benefits totally
and and I'm I'm not a doctor but when I play the
scenarios in my head and even my personal journey
to where I had to go to actually feel the food
noise stop maybe somebody in a smaller body only
needs 0.25 for the food noise but not the weight
like maybe the weight loss doesn't happen there
right you know so I don't know yeah there was a
study that came out Abby uh and I think we talked
about this one as well but it was did scientists
just discover the cure for addiction they're
tackling me three things because this is what you
know the I think it's the food noise alcohol and
smoking so apparently those are three things
that have most people who start ozampic have
stopped doing I do wonder if they're gonna start
tampering with it maybe so that there is no weight
loss component I don't know yeah we're gonna see
how this technology can be applied to other uh
comorbidities and things like that because yes
there's definitely a lot of overlap here and
I've got a question for you about that Ginger you
know obviously you came into this Desiring weight
loss and wanting to reduce your genetic risk of
diabetes and chronic disease but if you were not
to lose any weight on this drug would reducing the
food noise be worth some of the side effects and
costs and everything else associated with taking
those that big would there be any benefit to you
even without that weight loss piece that's a
great question I think yes in the sense that
the mental exhaustion is just gone in the sense
that sometimes now I have to go to a menu and
really think about what I'm eating instead
of just enjoying what might be good in that
sense Maybe not maybe I wouldn't want to take it
because now I do have to really think oh is that
fried oh does that have dairy oh that's really
going to affect me you know like which is fine
and I actually I feel much better having a salad
with grilled chicken like I feel that much better
so hi thanks for all those tips you know yeah
shocker um I think if it allowed me not to gain
more weight and to just be neutral and just live
then yes I think it's a worthwhile tool so long
as I wasn't overeating and just not gaining a lot
of it because the important thing for me obviously
is to take the weight off my knee so that I
can move right and I have a really interesting
um fear in this space from uh John and Stacy they
said my fear with stigma is that people will start
to say oh just go on ozempic to anyone that they
perceive to be unhealthy or overweight it will be
yet another way of blaming and shaming people for
being overweight personal choice is important and
I support body autonomy and all of us choosing
what's healthy for us but I feel this is going
to set us back in the body acceptance movement
and Society moving towards allowing us to all be
different what are your thoughts well I think
we talked we covered yes right yeah we did we
talked about this sort of like so John and Stacy
you kind of just nailed what we were yeah talking
about and I even talked about this back in my
original and pick video when I was kind of just
sharing my in the moment fears and hesitations
about ozempic you know I am scared that when I
see already thin folks who maybe have normal blood
sugars and healthy body weights take those then
our perception of what a healthy weight looks
like or what healthy looks like again becomes
even more skewed than I think it already is I
think you know for one we can't we can't look
at someone and determine if they are healthy that
dichotomy it's going to become even more black
and white in people's minds and I think as we've
already established this drug is very expensive
you know and so of course this opportunity is
going to be limited to folks who are financially
able to access it and that is unfair in a lot of
ways because then again we are granting people
the ability to have health or to look a certain
way and therefore be not judged by the populace
who have ideas about what is healthy what is
not healthy or what's a healthy look is going
to be limited to those who can afford it that
said as we just established I think there are
a lot of people who are prone to food noise and
other reward system disruptions for whom a drug
like ozempic that helps to silence that noise can
basically get them their life back so yeah there's
there's a lot of interesting studies and research
emerging specifically about ozone pick for these
reward system disruptions like you said addiction
and things like that and also for ozempic's wider
benefits for improving mood and well-being and
just ability to perform daily activities so I will
never I will never stand in the way of somebody
being able to access happiness whatever that may
look like I never want to speak out against that
because that's going to be different for everyone
of course that's going to come with disadvantages
for some populations but I don't think that means
that it's wrong or immoral for people to have
access to some of these medications that do
change lives totally and I think John and Stacy's
comment I think we have to keep that in our back
pocket and keep like coming back to that as more
studies come out as we keep talking about this
you know as we continue to like keep our finger
on the pulse of what people are saying like I'm
reading all the Reddit threads like there's will
go be weight loss there's an ozempic thread like
there's lots of really good threads to go to for
support and to just like read up on what people
are experiencing and because yeah I think the body
acceptance movement and body positivity movement
could be at risk like it is very very real however
as much as I want to accept how I look it doesn't
necessarily make me super happy so and I know
that's a societal problem and I just don't know
how to fix it other than feeling better about
myself from the inside out right so that's why I
like the approaching it you look happy or you look
like you're glowing it's going to be a struggle
but I think we should keep revisiting this comment
because I think it's a really really important
comment and I think yeah you could come up with so
many Myriad of ways and Avi I never even thought
about the wealth disparity issue you know wealth
is health or health as well to kind of like with
sitting back when you were saying that I'm like oh
God yeah I never thought about that I mean it is
much more cost effective to get the drug in Canada
than it is to get it in the state and yes we have
an obesity problem in Canada but there's a huge
obesity problem in the state so I mean we can't
solve everybody's problems like nobody can sell
a drug can't solve everybody's problems but I do
wonder what the drug the impact of the drug could
have on Health Care overall in Canada we cover so
many costs related to obesity and malnutrition as
people get older like diabetes like heart issues
and I do wonder if we took preventative stance
what that could look like for the overall cost
Savings of our Health Care system now this is
Canada specific obviously because we have we pay
into our Health Care system and it's um we have
free well it's not free it's not free it comes out
of our income taxes so anybody who says Healthcare
is not free right but we do have a Health Care
system that is available to all I think it's
quite obvious that socioeconomic status does
play a role in weight discrepancies and health
discrepancies Across the Nation in Canada in the
United States in a lot of these Western countries
so I think whether or not this is going to make
those discrepancies even greater or in other ways
possibly close a gap we're just going to have to
find out you know yes this drug has been around
for a long time but it hasn't been used by so many
people at the same time in history specifically
for weight loss so we're going to have to kind of
see what happens and and how it affects our
economy how it affects Public Health all of
those things so yes we're keeping our eyes on that
and also how it affects mental health too in the
mental health of the general population and I'm
sure there will be research coming out about that
because we always evaluate the mental health risks
of drugs and this has become such a big one this
is not like a drug we've ever had access to before
where it's just something oh yeah somebody who
needs that takes you know takes that drug no this
is like people know what a zenpick is exactly just
you know I sometimes I think back I'm like
I wonder if those voluptuous women in those
Renaissance paintings think about our generation
like probably I think they have all this money
and they're eating less like it makes no sense
they're thinking that's what the peasants did they
didn't eat very much we want to Feast oh my God
gosh I'm like you know Society is backwards when
the healthy food is double the price the cheap
you know the processed food again and this is
partially why we see these discrepancies in health
in folks in lower socioeconomic uh status groups
and so yeah we'll be adding a drug that costs
upwards of a thousand dollars a month to the
equation never mind healthy fruits and vegetables
they certainly are not going to be able to afford
that um but again let's see where this goes things
are always changing when it comes to price access
all of those things if we see that a drug like
this could make such a huge impact on our health
care then it may be in the financial interest of
the government to subsidize and things like that
so again we're going to keep our eyes we're not
going to know that for another year to five years
Etc so let's keep our fingers on that Ginger thank
you so much for sharing your journey I know it's
so helpful for so many people who are following
along folks please be kind this time as you can
see your words have impact let's cheer ginger
on and and share others on in the comments who
are going through their own Journeys and I really
appreciate all of you guys sharing your thoughts
your tips your struggles in the comments as well
and Ginger keep it up two milligrams today good
luck yeah I'm looking forward to hearing about
it and I I really do hope that the side effects
aren't too bad for you and you continue to to
be have that smile on your face that's what we
want to see oh thanks Abby this was this was
great and I'm really looking forward to our
next chat and that John and Stacy comment is
going to stay at the back of my head mine too
long always yeah always I think as we consume
ozampic content in the media through celebrity
culture I think we always have to have that in
the back of our mind as a bit of a threat you
know it's a bit of a threat to all of us and
it harms all of us when we let that become the
The Narrative that this is what a healthy body
looks like so just keep that in mind everyone I
definitely am and I think you should too as well
Ginger will do all right Ginger thank you so much
bye and all that notes guys I hope you
enjoyed this video if you did be sure
to give it a thumbs up subscribe to this Channel
and I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]